so yeah it's been it's been a good gig I
definitely can kind of see like the
horizon of where I'm gonna hit like
critical mass and it's like time to sort
of piss or get off the pot when it comes
to comedy or like I'll have done as much
as I can do with the time I have while
working full-time because right now
between like my job and like all the
things I do producing and writing and
teaching them all that like I'm
definitely working like 80 hours a week
like it's a lot that's really you know
yeah and I don't think I can do my best
at all of those things at the same time
anymore so I am kind of like a
crossroads where I'm having to side what
am I gonna do what's your what's your
plan
[Music]
alright alright so we're yeah that's
your adventure waters here we go alright
let's give you a proper intro okay okay
hop read the verse welcome back to the
hot breath podcast this is your weekly
guide to comedy mastery I am your host
comedian Joel Byers and our guest today
yes
this is comedy worlds colliding right
here I feel like this is the first of
many we will be doing here she is at
lanta base chameleon by way of Chicago
whose always had a knack for
entertaining whether it be through
childhood musical troops or being on the
speech team or working at a radio
station but it wasn't until a OKCupid
day to an open mic that inspired her to
pursue comedy needless to say that date
bombed but comedy wins because we now
have this inspirational comedian to my
left or right whatever you say
long story short she's only been doing
comedy around five years and has already
started her own comedy organization
called Wendy peach that not only creates
original content it also produces local
shows and there's a third one who's
local shows content we might be on the
intro I can't believe I actually I
honestly did not mean to write I've been
working hard on these intros and I was
like in here rehearsing and I'm like I'm
gonna get this is the first one okay
it's classes and workshops yeah
definitely a viable resource so
definitely support her there because
she's all about helping comedy which is
what we're doing here as well Mike Maps
as well as something she's
hang on an app that gives you just open
mics at your fingertips so a lot of good
things going on if you find this episode
helpful reach out to her personally let
her know how valuable this was ask her
questions reach out to us ask questions
but if you do enjoy this all we ask
share this with other comedians and
comedy fans subscribe to our YouTube
channel and our iTunes and that being
said after all that Sam Gordon welcome
to the hot breath averse thank you I
can't believe I'm finally here we share
such a similar like mission and passion
we do have like very parallel
trajectories yeah all the way you always
have something new you're always
creating content and you're always
falling through and the things that you
started which I didn't realize you only
been doing comedy like five years yeah
seeing all the things you're doing I was
like wow only five years yeah I think I
was really lucky but I had kind of a
head start since I did other kinds of
entertainment and I also had done a lot
of other kinds of production before I
started so I feel like I didn't have to
learn the ropes per se as much as I had
to learn how to like reapply my skills
in a new job if that makes sense
you're like on miss Maggie's just
pointed toward you so and you seems like
you're kind of on a mission cuz like
only five years like you're producing
several shows you're doing classes five
years into my career I may have been
hosting one open mic so the end you
start this organization it's like you're
clearly on a mission here in Swords yes
I think for me I don't know I I feel
like I found comedy late in life which I
know is silly because I'm 29 now but it
does it does feel it cuz I feel like you
know you go to open mics and you go to
shows and you even see I have so many
friends who were a little younger than
me but they started in college or
they've been doing it you know a couple
years longer and I feel like they're
that much further ahead so I think
that's been part of it is I'm just like
oh my god I don't want to be 35 and had
open mikes only like I'm cool to still
do open mics forever but I hope there's
a credit when they bring me
you know yeah how's your leg part of it
is extreme anxiety of being behind which
is how I've always been in everything in
life okay and then part of it is this I
I don't know I generally just I really
like people that's always been like the
driving force and all of the different
jobs and hobbies have taken up I like
working with people and I like seeing
people do things that they love to do
like which is why I love like seeing
live music and I love seeing live comedy
I love seeing theater like I cry at
every play I've ever been to you know
good so for me I think it's just been
important to make sure that comedy feels
welcoming and feels like it's for
everybody because I've definitely seen
it not be that way over the years and I
just want to create a corner that makes
people feel as good as I know comedy can
make people feel you know yeah and you
you wrote a blog that Sam Gordon comedy
comm check it out you wrote a good blog
there really resonated with me in terms
of like you you started comedy in
Chicago and then you move to Atlanta but
you felt like almost in orbit of the
scene yeah and I feel like a lot of
comedians feel that way in a comedy
scene where they're like boo why am I
not on that really cool show that
happens at midnight that only like
homeless people yeah I want my face on
that flyer we can all get in our heads
but why not me have you been able to
like combat that oh man I mean I wish I
had a clear answer cuz I cry about it at
least once over I always feel left out
constantly which i think is important
cuz it's like even though I feel like
I'm one of the most doing doers in
Atlantica yeah I know I'm doing a lot
and my name in my face or a lot of
places I still feel like a loser all the
time like I don't know if it ever goes
away and I think especially because of
social media you just see it on a loop
and it seems like everybody's doing
everything without you right it's really
not true everyone also feels like a
loser and doesn't feel invited but I
don't know I think it's the biggest
thing for me was getting over that like
desperate need to be picked and I
definitely still complain about that a
lot or like I wish someone would pick me
because sometimes I do feel like my
success isn't fully valid it's like I
made it all up myself like I need my own
jobs and I'm like I'm a CEO
what myself so like sometimes I don't
feel that good about what I've done
could doesn't seem like big enough cuz I
wasn't chosen for it but I think the big
thing for me is just deciding like no I
can make my own opportunities and those
can be good too and I don't know I feel
like if you just keep doing the thing
that you like to do and you just keep
getting better and better at it
eventually someone's gonna notice right
mm-hmm like if and if you don't believe
that you should quit right now cuz
that's like the only hope you have to
hold on to it was like eventually
someone will notice me
yeah focusing on what you can continue
like you know trying to get people's
attention just focus on like what you
can make as an individual and have
something to offer people yes I think
that's the biggest thing is giving
yourself some kind of I don't know just
viability or it's like well even if they
don't pick me I got this thing going on
and then eventually someone notice that
you're working hard you know you hope
and your attention to detail as well cuz
a lot of comedians will complain but why
not me and then if someone did go to see
like your website or whatnot they'd be
like oh well why would I go see them
like your website it has like a media
kit it has press you've done it I mean
it is like a full-blown resume of
totally and I think that that school
came from working in radio the for
comedy and when I say working in radio
it was not glamorous and anyway it was
like local low-power FM and Round Lake
Illinois and the Chicago suburbs herself
credit that I know I mean hey I was
right I was only 15 when I lied my way
into that station why would you say well
okay so there's this local station 93 FM
wror
and there's a weekly show called J
Street radio and it started out as a
zine it was like a local access cable
show then became this radio show and it
always focused on local bands and I was
one of those like little scene kids like
at like the VFW to see her like crushes
hardcore band like like I was a
photographer for a few years quote you
know
yeah yeah I was that girl die hard I
really just wanted to be the kid an
almost famous like that was my goal and
listen this local show every week is
like my friends bands would be on it and
I heard that they were like advertising
an internship you had to be 18 and I was
like well that doesn't seem right
because I want it so I wrote them in
like a very passionate email about like
all the reasons why they should let a
minor into the radio station and
apparently it was just detailed enough
that like the host of the show brought
it to the management the station was
like alright well this kid really wants
to be here and I don't think anybody
else did yeah right but yeah they had
like my parents signed some waivers and
then every week my mom would drop me off
with the radio station and you know over
a course of a couple years I went up
from you I was being like the intern
that would like greet the band's when
they came and got him coffee
sorting records to being an on-air host
and I got to interview bands I got to
write for the zine I started writing for
other publications doing that like that
really set me on a really cool
trajectory and by being in that
environment and watching that like DIY
yeah that came from Jesse at Jay Street
like that's where I learned how to like
market yourself how to just like make it
yourself that was my first introduction
to that yeah which is lucky because I
kind of you know since I was 15 I've
never thought that I couldn't just make
up my own job I just trusted I could as
a comedian
we everyone should have that mindset
yeah you got it well that's the thing
too we think especially coming into it
as as a woman you know as a queer person
as you know anything that's not you know
three specific types of white guy that
we seem to love see everywhere in comedy
you're using it for good yeah sure
you've got the face of evil good good
outlier yeah I do
coming into it as someone who's not like
the traditional comedian it can be
really frustrating because you come in
looking for your place and there really
isn't a place for you because like no
one's even looking for you like let
alone someone who's like a minority or
any other kind of Li different so I
think that like DIY mindset is super
crucial to like not letting the I don't
know the standard sort of like kill your
career because just because there isn't
a place for you doesn't mean there
shouldn't be and sometimes you need to
make one and show people why it would be
good to use you and that's where that
DIY is really important in comedy I
think it's important with like DIY
do-it-yourself
is having an it so not not complaining
not wearing but we'll look at all this
awesome stuff other people are doing
will create something awesome for you
like we don't have an it and like you
have the resume you've you've put in the
foundation so if someone does find you
in that or a fan yeah I think that's
been my thing is just like trying to be
prepared for like so if I do get an
opportunity I have to show people so
like that's been my thing this last
particularly the last like two years I'd
say the first three years of comedy I
was really just trying to figure out how
stand-up worked I was figuring out like
the social part of how you like get
booked and I was just like working on
you know being a comedian cuz like when
I started I was way too loud way too big
on stage I was always moving my hands
and squatting like a Little League coach
you know like I just trying way too hard
I had this like platinum blonde pixie
cut and I always were these like loud
ass floral dresses and I was like
feminism which is great a great message
but like not a great way to deliver it
to just like punch people in the face
with it so it took me time to like
develop the like stealthy way to talk
about the issues I want to talk about
that no one wanted to hear about
and develop my voice and once I felt
like I'd hit a place or like okay I'm
getting booked regularly people like my
set I like my set now I feel like I can
you know brand and like I built my
website my first year in standup just
because I thought having a booking email
might help me get booked and guess what
it did yeah it's crazy how much you can
just trick people into thinking you're a
professional if you've got a website see
yeah that's all true
when I I mean before I did comedy back
with like the music stuff when I was
branching out from the station and I
wanted to get more writing jobs I made a
wordpress blog called reviews ik where
we knew he would be use ik I was 20 you
know what can you do but you know I
would write these articles where I'd
review bands and I'd go to those shows
and I do write-ups about it that no one
was asking you to do but I wanted to
make it look like it was a professional
web site so I made up a bunch of pen
names and fake profiles for writers on
my staff I made myself the editor of the
blog and then every day I would have
like six articles a day I'd schedule
like weeks in advance and all these
writers would just be posting articles
I'm like oh my god here's his girl
running a music paper like oh look at
this publication but it was just me and
I used that to get my first writing job
like that's how I got freelance jobs cuz
I was like look at all this stuff I can
do oh my but yeah I had kind of the same
approach when I started stand-up I was
like I'm gonna get nice photos of myself
I'm gonna build the website I'm gonna
get a good tape I'm gonna put it all on
there and then I'm gonna go to shows and
I'm gonna follow up with the host the
next day say hey love the show we'd love
to be considered here's my website and
it worked
ya know it yeah it's crazy what you can
do if you just manipulate the system
well fake it til you make it in exactly
you do cuz yeah who's gonna who's gonna
give you that opportunity unless you
show them that you can handle it so you
got to figure out the over around and
through of it but I think it's important
people to hear you focused on funny
first I got running first get funny
first I got funny get funny first and
then I tried to build an empire yes
yeah I think that's really important and
I will say like when I was first
starting out like in Chicago I tried to
run two different shows one was a
fundraiser show ironically I was for the
lillas fund which is on organization in
Texas that supports abortion rights
which is funny because I'm doing the
same thing now but for in Georgia
oh that's all it's funny that it was
still following her but I tried doing a
show it was called friends with benefit
and it was a disaster
it did not go well it was terrible I was
awful at hosting and nobody was doing I
just booked all my friends from
open-mike none of us were good it was
bad it was a bad show we only did it
once and then we were done did you bomb
oh yeah terrible terrible I had some
joke about like jazz enthusiast but miss
hearing it as like jizz Oh
doing its back and show you some tape
the most things you've ever heard I was
just trying to hang with the boys at the
open mic that I was trying way too hard
to hang with the boys over at Kohl's
open mic in shock which is one of the
best of mics ever but yeah I was just
trying too hard and then I started a
show called the combo like a year later
that was a variety show cuz I was
working at improv Olympic at i/o cool
and I started a show there that had like
stand-up and music and improv and sketch
and all sorts of stuff and that was
really successful we got like a
six-month run it was super fun but then
the Future Sight not to renew it I was
crushed I hated myself and then I tried
it at another theater got a few month
run they said not to renew it crushed
hated myself
and then I like took a step back and
spent more time like researching other
people's shows and figuring out like
well how are they marketing how are they
hosting who were they booking how does
the show format work and then I didn't
try and run another show until earlier
why like last year I started another
show was that the vinci's yeah it was
the open mic cuz it's been over a year
now a year now so that was the first
show I really was running like I was
doing here at high wire a little bit but
it wasn't really a regular thing kind of
happened when they needed someone to
fill in a slot and I still don't really
know what is due
yeah I started doing the open mic and
then like a few months later I got the
opportunity to start working with don't
tell comedy yeah come up you know that's
a huge that's like that's another thing
all I did was ask truthfully I thought
about it I had a friend in Boston Sam
Mike amazing comedian and he was telling
me about how he did it don't tell comedy
show on a boat in Boston Harbor and I
was like that's amazing he's like you
should look it up and I looked it up and
I'm like oh they're in all these other
cities it's pop-up show people just
rotate the show around into venues that
aren't traditional comedy spaces and
it's in 30 cities now but when I looked
it up I realize Atlanta wasn't on the
list so I shot them an email and I was
like hey do you guys want to bring it to
Atlanta and then we you know we talked
on the phone for a while went back and
forth and then you know within a month I
was running it so we had our first show
in January of this year we just did our
tenth show this last week and we're
doing like two or three a month now
forever like as long as we want to you
because people love it I guess they're
packed and they're amazing cuz yeah and
they've created a really cool product
and that's another thing is like me
seeking out people who are doing a thing
I wanted to do the matter then I was
able to at my level boom and asking to
be like taken with being like hey I want
to do what you're doing what can I do to
either learn from you or be part of it
and then I was really lucky where I got
invited to be part of it so I got both
but I think it's good to look at people
who are making the thing you want to
make and ask them about it like in this
last year - I've had so many comics come
up to me and ask to like grab a coffee
and like have a chat and like I always
will meet up with people and sit down
and talk and like share what I can share
and I think that's awesome I think more
people should do that yes I think we
should all do that I was just on the
phone with the comic on the way here I
hit me up I'll share any information I
have yes I just want everything to be
fun I just want to have as many cool
shows as possible I don't get the
competitiveness
yeah it's there's there's enough for
everyone yeah well you know a rising
tide floats all ships right yeah exactly
he built a really cool community it's
gonna attract bigger headliners and
attract more production like we're the
product you know keep adding to it
how are you marketing your shows you
said you kind of learn to the marketing
I know yeah Don't Tell is always packed
Don't Tell is like so most of what we do
with Don't Tell is honesty through
Facebook marketing okay um and I think
part of that is just because they
started in a pretty large pool like they
started the first shows in Boston and
then it like really took off as the
company it is now when they moved it to
LA and started doing it in cities along
the coast and so I think that just like
attracted like a general Facebook
presence and then they have like
targeted marketing for all the
individual events in each city but I
also got a figure like because of the
algorithms work just because they have
like like any given weekend they can
have up to like 20 show is happening in
20 cities so it's like a lot of don't
tell flashing around but yeah the target
of marketing but for me personally for
the shows that I run I think the best
marketing has been I talked to everybody
huh I talked to everybody I mean I
always have in the elevator coming up to
meet you this guy asked me what are you
doing on the fifth floor weird question
but I'm going to do a podcast with the
comedian you know bubble is like oh you
do comedy I'm like yeah actually I run
some shows here you go and I gave him a
windy peach sticker I gave him my card
for don't tell and I was like me if you
want tickets and that's it I always give
people a free ticket and then they
usually start coming to my shows like oh
you see you you show you have like an
actual ticket it's like a free um no cuz
everything is digital but yeah I said
like a card like a business card I'll
give people it has my email on it and I
see it's emailing take a look at the
calendar pick out a date shoot me an
email and I'll give you tickets if you
want to get savvy um and that's helped a
lot because I feel like it building that
personal connection people remember it
longer and also everyone loves to be
approached the same way as comedians we
want people to ask us and approach us I
do feel like audience members like want
to be wanted like I feel like they can
appreciate like I mean don't hound
people but like it's a thing where it's
like interact with people make a
personal connection invite them to
something if you do see them at the show
be like hey thanks for coming like take
a second to talk to people afterwards
and I feel like people remember that
personal connection cuz everyone loves
to be able to say like oh yeah I know
that person like if they send a picture
on something and their name somewhere
and
it feels cool and you can be a civilians
into thinking you're a celebrity if you
really smooth so you seem to have a
really good knack for just kind of like
building it and they will come yeah yeah
I do I feel like if you put on something
consistent and you just I don't know I
always just tell people to be pleasant
and present that's like my like life
motto is I just try to be nice and try
to be like focus on the people that
you're talking to like really pay
attention to like where you are in the
moment cuz you never know who you're
gonna meet or like I don't know I've
just made so many random connections
like at a don't tell show a woman you
know came to a show thought it was great
send me an email asked me if I would
help her put on a show an all-female
showcase at her art gallery for this
all-female like week-long event she was
doing oh my god I was like yeah great so
we put that on and now we're doing one
of my reproductive fundraisers in her
gallery we're doing another don't tell
wonder comedies gonna be using that
while their space is under construction
and like it's open those beautiful
relationship just because I said hi to
her at the end of the show and like told
her to email me if she ever wanted to
come back like easy-peasy
you know so it's like you never know
who's gonna be there and how they can
help you or how you could help them so
especially when you have a quality
product to provide so another
reiteration comedian you need to get
funny funny fibers get funny or you may
get that opportunity and he'll never
come back around right exactly and
you'll have like this great show and
then you'll say something about jizz
enthusiasts instead of jasmine and in
that that are Taylor's show turns into a
one-off instead of this repeat right
opportunity but yeah I think having like
a package like you mentioned the media
kit yeah say I think that's been huge
for me
because even just having that like I
showed up in like a Google search for a
marketing company because of my website
and now every month I get invited to
movie screenings for comedies what yeah
and I get all this like free swag they
send me to help them promote their new
movies and it's just cuz she found me in
a Google search because I had all the
tags on my website you know silly stuff
like that yeah and that's led into this
cool relationship or like now I get
stuff for like the raffles for my shows
and like you know it connects you know
it all connects yeah I think having the
media kits important I think you just
need to have a solid clip between like
five to ten
mm-hmm that people can see and hear you
clearly you know some photos about your
stuff would be nice and a little bio is
good and that's really all you need to
get started and from there again every
time you do something like a podcast or
like a really cool show that has
beautiful photos whatever edit your
website throw it up on the blog let
people know what you're doing sometimes
it feels really stupid to try and I
think that's like a thing in comedy
we're like I remember like when I made
my website and I got myself business
cards now truthfully I've been doing it
for a year so I did look like an idiot
why they're really nice business cards
and a really nice website and like dang
it I was trying don't make fun of me for
trying but everybody did or like when I
made like my my Facebook page I was so
like embarrassed and mortified by it had
so many people ask how they could find
me and Facebook's the easiest way just
tell him hey look me up on Facebook like
here you go yeah and I finally made it
and I felt so embarrassed to like ask
people to come like it but you know what
it's worked out so well and it's helped
me so much like who cares there's always
gonna be people who make fun of you for
trying too hard but most the time those
are people who are just insecure that
they're not trying hard enough
yeah they're just project don't worry
about it and that's why it is important
to surround yourself with people doing
what you want to do like not if you you
can get around an open mic and get
around the same curmudgeon people that
are just at the same open mics doing the
same jokes never trying to get better
but really be proactive if you want to
get better be around other comics that
are getting better and doing what you
want to do well that's why I tell people
all the time is to just stick around to
the open mic for like three or four
slots after your spot watch what other
people are doing
hey that shows that like you care a
little bit to support the show I noticed
that as a host I always pay attention I
did too as a host I always pay attention
to who wants to be there yep and then
you also will like pick up on either
what to do or what not to do by watching
people and I think you can't
underestimate the importance of like not
going to an open mic one night and
instead going to a showcase where there
are people who are very good at comedy
to accommodate
exactly and observing that or even just
like staying home and listening to your
sets and like editing yourself and I
think people get caught up in the
romance of like the late nights and
hanging out and like hitting as many
mics as you can the grind and it doesn't
help those people aren't funny they're
just not they're tired and they're
crabby and they're not nice to be around
you know and I was one of those people
you know I was like tired and hungover
for the first like two years I did
stand-up because I thought that's how
you did it like oh no you can approach
is like a job yeah exactly and I was
like no needle II put in hours like
working on my my tasks which is writing
jokes and you know promoting myself and
developing my presence and my job wasn't
you know drinking vodka sodas at Star
Bar till wanting my god if what is in
thinking of speaking of jobs actually
like dude do you have a day job I do
have a day job man okay right now I'm an
e4 boy girl twins it's very exhausting
yeah they're there almost two I've been
with them since they were two months old
so yeah I try the longest job I've had
in a minute I used to be I used to call
myself the part-time hero because I just
worked six part-time jobs everyday until
I died yeah I just you know for someone
who has as many skills as I have you
would think I would have found like a
career but I just really never did
I haven't found like a job job that I've
ever stuck with I've just done a lot of
different things that I've been pretty
good at but nothing that's ever been
like I should do this oh yeah I mean I
jumped around yeah but all would the
pursuit of comedy in the back right I
always knew I wanted to write in some
shape or form it took me a while to
figure out like how I wanted to do it
but once I did I decided like okay well
let's focus on a job that gives me
flexibility and oddly enough being a
nanny really is like the best job for
comedian for the hours
yeah it's steady and they usually sleep
part of the day if you pick the right
ages to nanny more they'll be in school
so you're working part-time and usually
you're done by five or six so it's like
enough time to get to shows I mean yet
sex I usually have to be at work at like
7:30 in the morning it's kind of hard
but yeah I've done that but also it
keeps you for spending your whole night
drinking and being an idiot it makes you
go do your set go home go to bed
attack the day healthy the next day
because you're in charge of life you're
in charge of lives you're enjoy the
future of the world yeah yeah definitely
so yeah it's been it's been a good gig I
definitely can kind of see like the
horizon of where I'm gonna hit like
critical mass and it's like time to sort
of piss or get off the pot when it comes
to comedy or like I'll have done as much
as I can do with the time I have while
working full-time cuz right now between
like my job and like all the things I do
producing and writing and teaching them
all that like I'm definitely working
like 80 hours a week like it's a lot
that's really you know yeah and I don't
think I can do my best at all of those
things at the same time anymore so I am
kind of at like a crossroads where I'm
having to side what am I gonna do what's
your what's your plan I don't really
know I think I definitely like wanna I'm
trying to like stick it out to stay
working with my family until the kids go
into like daycare at pre-k because
really isn't too far down the road but
if I can't I don't know I don't know cuz
I'd like to do is I'd like to focus more
on producing I really like running shows
I really like organizing shows I think
I'm getting pretty good at it I'd like
to do don't tell every week if I can but
that but don't tell that's like a lot of
work because I have to scout venues I
have to set up those relationships I
have to go check them to make sure they
are good I have to book comics I have to
show up I have to set up I mean I've got
40 folding chairs and a PA system in my
house yeah hey doll you it's on me baby
I got volunteers I get people who like
volunteer and then I let them bring a
couple friends to the show for free but
yeah more often than not it's just me
and hopefully a very friendly person at
the venue who's willing to help me load
in some chairs mm-hmm
but I actually been really surprised by
how many people will volunteer for don't
tell we got a lot of audience members
who just think it's super cool and they
want to like come back for free so they
come and like work the door or something
just sweet but yeah I'd love to do more
don't tell it's just you know it takes a
lot of time and energy and then the
stuff in noon with Wendy peach like
right now I'm producing like the open
mic and a Monday night show but I've
gotten some opportunities to do other
shows other places but I just don't know
when I'd physically have the time
to go do that with what I'm doing right
now so I would love to be able to like
leave my job on like a happy now get
them and replace my nanny and like you
know fly off on an umbrella like Mary
Poppins comeback and Mary Poppins too
when they're adults and then be able to
focus on just trying to do what I'm
doing now but like a little bit more
because they also have like other like
tiny little irons in the fire like
there's a great website called comedy
wire yeah there's like a sort of set up
like Reddit and there's like a part
that's free where you can just like
write headline jokes and you know fun
stuff and eventually like if you get up
voted and people like liked your
material on there they might invite you
to the pro side which is mostly just
like a bunch of freelance gigs for like
radio and podcast commercials for like
jewelers it's like not very exciting or
money but every so often there's like a
cool go down there like I've gotten to
write tweets for like Wendy's and I've
gotten to UM you know write copy for
like big festivals like stuff like that
this is all paid work yeah and it's you
know there's different bids not a lot
but if you know you write a couple ads a
day and you win the bid because you post
your bid and your like competing with
other people for the bid and then the
client will pick their favorite and then
you'll either split the pot if multiple
ones get picked or you get to take the
whole pot only usually between like 10
and 30 bucks but sometimes they're more
sometimes they're like a couple hundred
and they do like contests and giveaways
the vase gave away like a free year of
that masterclass you know that like
online class like Judd Apatow tmartn
stuff they had like a contour right in
contest like right a Steve Martin s quip
and then they picked their favorite one
in that person won a year of master
classes
this is comedy wire yeah so like there's
a lot a lot of little stuff you can get
out of it but yeah I would love to like
focus on doing more of that during the
day and you know submitting articles to
people because I would love to like
write again that's not comedy
necessarily yeah yeah you're I'd love to
audition I have you know i've got a
voice-over demo but i've never done an
audition in atlanta you know they mean
like and it's just cuz i haven't had the
time
I've never even like pursued getting
like management are getting
representation which i think is
something I'm starting to need to move
on to the next thing I want to do but to
do that I'm gonna have to free up about
40 hours of my website I can see where I
might be able to make more income and
sustain myself but it's also just like
such a huge risk and that's very
nerve-racking for me when I when I
decided to go full-time I made a list of
like all the pros and cons of like okay
if I go full-time what are all the
awesome things that could happen what's
the worst-case scenario what could
happen and the pros far outweighed the
cons and I was just like were you were
you married at that point like you were
I was not single I was living in a
studio apartment in on Boulevard I was
like the frontlines of gentrification
but and I was I was a hotel minibar
attendant so like I worked my way I like
was at enterprise and then I gradually
from there took jobs that paid less but
gave me more time and I kind of weaned
myself into comedy full-time that way
and I had a I saved up ten thousand
dollars yeah and that's just what I
jumped into comedy with I was like okay
I have $10,000 let me that was like goal
one save that and then I did all my pros
and cons and was like well it seems like
which is weird
it is it's like this is what I was born
to do wait should I dunno it's finally
here but it is like when you when you
step into that world then the world will
start to reveal itself to you and his
opportunities will start to yeah you got
to kind of like take the leave you know
yeah you can't be available if you're
not there you know it's like what I keep
telling myself cuz yeah I think for me
like my plan I see all these like little
things I can do to sustain myself I have
the time I have some opportunities with
some clubs that like nationally that
like me maybe could book a more Road
work I could start doing next I really
haven't done much of that yeah and I
could you know pick up a part-time job I
could do little things here and there
like there's always ways to make little
amounts of money you know I just
to like remind myself like it can be
done and it's not like binary to where
it's all or nothing there are life and
steps you can take job like you said
come like bridge jobs where it's like
just a part-time thing that'll get you
to the next totally yeah and my hope too
is that if I do pick up another you know
if let's say I leave this job and I pick
up another part-time job I'm hoping that
I can get something that's a little bit
more industry adjacent yeah I like if
I'm spending you know if I'm gonna spend
my time somewhere I want it to be you
know where I'm gonna be around people
who might be able to help me down the
road really I'm gonna build
relationships and I'm not really
building relationships home alone with
two babies right I'm not meeting anybody
maybe some of these venues you're doing
don't tell that yeah you know you're
doing it some cool place yeah there's
some really cool places and there's a
few that we've talked about like
extending the content and like running
our own show out of that space and I've
been able to leg lens spaces I've found
to other comics who need venues and
maybe that's something like maybe that's
my skill is like building relationships
finding venues and then I can help
people set up shows and act as a
producer and not even have to host it
you know like because that is what I'm
really good at I'm a great host but I'm
a better producer and I'm good at
telling who's capable of doing what and
I feel like I could hire people to do
that you know like long-term I want to
do that and I want to give other people
those opportunities because I want the
bigger thing you know I think that's the
thing too about leveling up is realizing
that if you want to get up to the top
you can't still be doing the work that's
at the bottom you've got to learn to
delegate you've got to find people you
can trust and you gotta which is like
something I'm working on now is trying
to find people who will show up for me
and who I can like let co-host stuff or
let take over something for me so I can
move on to the next thing that I want to
do which is why it's important comics be
around yeah be really nice because I
tell you what I'm definitely paying
attention to people who are consistently
kind and that kind when I'm posting
about spots oh I had people that when I
hosted my show that like just
belligerently ran the light and will
never be back yeah I know when I see
them I'm like you're at the problem I'm
running into right now with my Monday
night and this is like a little gossip
but the problem I'm running in tune with
my Monday night now is that very often
you know I'll book people a few weeks in
advance and then the day of the show
they find out they're booked on a
different Monday night show that doesn't
tell them until the day of right and
they've been told that they can't come
to you my show or that they you know
they need to be there at 8:00 to get a
spot on the show that they've been
booked for which I think is a very
interesting method for running things
but but because of that they've been
asked to decline another spot despite
the fact that my show ends at the same
time that show is supposed to begin and
we all know it never starts on time so I
just find it very frustrating to have
people treat my show like it's an option
yeah when they get a better opportunity
and like I'm watching that I'm paying
attention never forget them because why
would I bring you up with me if you are
ready to drop me the second something
better comes along that means that you
don't value me you don't value my
product and honestly you don't really
value yourself because why would you let
someone tell you where you're allowed to
do your stage time mm-hmm have some
dignity man I just don't think anybody
is worth telling you how to spend your
time as a performer it's a professional
courtesy it's like people that show up
late to your show and then want to go up
early like it's just little things like
that that I think comics it their easel
easy mistakes that can be avoided
totally and being good person I know
sometimes I set people up for failure
with that a little bit cuz I'm a little
too nice we're like on the outside I'm
like you know no worries no problem but
in my head I'm like you're honest you
know like like I'd like I like don't
don't take my my kindness for weakness
exactly which I think has been a big
issue for me in history is I've gotten
I've gotten steamrolled a lot and then
when I say something everyone's like why
are you being such a [ __ ] it's like
well cuz I'm feeling pretty [ __ ] right
now you know but yeah and that's been a
lesson to is learning to that not
everyone is deserving of my kindness not
it wants deserving of my generosity and
I can be way too overeager to offer
people stuff just because like I want
people to come and enjoy it and see what
I'm doing and then all of a sudden I've
got like ten people who are looking like
go to spot tonight and they're mad if I
can't put them up and it's like well
already booked six people like what yeah
yeah I would recommend all comics run a
show
just so they understand oh yeah just
well one posting is great experience
I've learned more from hosting than oh
yeah I've gotten so much funnier this
year from hosting that open mic
oh I've learned so much yeah and then
running a show gives you a whole new
appreciation for you guys the work you
just respect people's time a lot more
and you can't stand how hard it is to
book and you understand you know that
question that's why not why didn't they
book me or why they booking them instead
yeah you start booking shows you start
figuring out why you booked certain
people and not others you know yeah it
doesn't even come down to talent
sometimes it's about how they act at the
show do they respect the light do they
respect you like this you learn a lot
yeah I do I think it'd be great to start
an open mic that has like you know like
a central host to like kick things off
but then it is it's like a baton Pass
open mic we're like other comics have to
host and take turns hosting for like 5
comics at a time that's a good idea
because it is a skill we all need to
learn but not everyone's capable of
going and starting a show but yeah
everyone needs that experience and I
think open mic is a great way to learn
like yeah it can be really brutal up
here and sometimes you still have to
like keep the posi
even if the show suck so you got to
pretend it's really fun of court and you
that you're happy to be there here so
thankful even that it's the every week
you're there even though everyone's
complaining what do you you you've
booked so many shows like what do you
look for in a venue um okay well like
don't tell the ideal things for a venue
are overhead lights that turn completely
off so we can make the venue totally
black and we'll have our own light
stands and lighting to make it look nice
yeah oh yeah I mean they're just like
amazonbasics but they work they work co
lights have turned all the way off so we
can get that sexy stage lighting we've
always got like a banner I'm a big fan
of the banner because then you can turn
any venue into like a
professional-looking space and it's
literally it's from Vistaprint
it's very cheap don't put it outside it
will bend in half but yeah it's just
like a little retractable banner that
you pull up and it's like six and a half
feet tall and it's really beautiful and
it makes a stage look like you're
somewhere professional yeah and I think
like having a banner or a sign just some
kind of branding that makes people they
feel like they're at an event
not just like a building it's important
and venues with low ceilings I feel like
people underestimate that we want summer
that has like tight sound you have a big
equity open space you're just gonna have
a lot of difficulty hearing people or
the sounds I'm gonna carry it's gonna
sound really tinny all your video will
be terrible so I think that's important
but more than anything I think it's just
important to find a place that I don't
know how its kind of a vibe or that you
can like bring a vibe to and people who
are excited to have you there that's a
big thing I need to be very very
cautious about the people that you
choose to invest yourself with and that
goes really picking venues not not
everyone who's willing to work with you
is the right person to work with and
I've definitely been approached by
businesses that like want us to put the
show on there and I take a look at their
space their layout whatever and it's
like it's just not gonna it's just not
gonna look good it's gonna be hard to
get people in and out it's just not a
good space and people are like salty
about it but you got to do what's good
for the show um but yeah I think this is
important to pick a place that's like
kind of easy to get to a little bit of
parking and more importantly just you
can create an atmosphere in this is the
same fewer open mics to where you look
yeah how do you okay no I mean it makes
a difference I mean my show is a bit of
a challenge we do out on a patio in
Midtown right across from the Art Center
Marta so it's kind of noisy oh they'll
usually mellows out by like 8:30 you
know traffic dies down it's pretty chill
but you know like we're outdoors
sometimes it's hot sometimes it's cold
you can hear the exhaust fan from the
pizza kitchens it's kind going if you
listen open mic it's a real open-air
mine but I will say like you know the
people at that space love having us like
da Vinci's loves having the open mic
they've been so incredibly supportive at
our one-year anniversary show they gave
away like a hundred dollars worth of
gift certificates whoa they're always
giving away specials and drinks for the
comics like they're very supportive of
what we're doing and that's why the show
has been successful because it's like
they want me to succeed I want to
succeed for them we're both like
bringing positivity into the environment
then you know people show up and they
either are there for or they're not and
if people are negative about the
environment you know get people
complaining about being on a patio
complain about the fans whatever you
know I tell them that they can just
leave how did you approach the venue
actually the venue approached me I got
really lucky so there's a really
talented comedian writer actor named
John Waring that I worked with on good
evening tonight that news satire show
yes do a high-wire and he's like the PR
marketing guy over there and they were
doing trivia for a while and it wasn't
very successful so they wanted to
replace it and initially they were gonna
have me be the new trivia host and then
I went we didn't do trivia we tried the
thing I actually do comedy and so yeah
they're like okay let's give it a shot
let's see how it goes and it went pretty
well and when we started we were getting
like 15 people on the list now we get
like 30 and it's just from like showing
up and being consistent and I think the
biggest feedback I've gotten about my
mic is a lot of people feel very little
there and they feel very like free to
fail yeah people don't feel stupid at my
mic which is really important to me
because I've been a lot of places that
made me feel dumb for trying yeah I feel
dumb for like trying to socialize like
it's like clicky and weird like I try
really hard to like acknowledge when
there's a face I haven't seen before and
be like hey like this is your first time
like thanks so much for coming out right
you know anyone like have you met
so-and-so and like I've got like a few
comics who are always there that I know
are nice and they're like my wingmen
that I'm like hey I'm gonna introduce
you to someone talk to them before we
start the show so they feel welcome and
yeah and it's like really well when we
got a lot of people who come for their
first set they bring all their friends
it's super cute like it's nice I feel
like it's a very sweet wholesome room
and I think that's just been like what I
always wanted in an open mic was like a
space where I didn't feel like I had had
my guard up or like feel stupid if my
joke bombed or like worried that some
guy was gonna be creepy to me like
because we don't really let anyone get
away with anything at the open mic like
I'm very quick to tell people like hey
we don't say that word here hey we don't
talk about women like that
yeah hold on that was racist all right
all right get my hand yeah
it's just like giving people a gentle
nudge to let them know like hey this is
the culture I'm creating and you can
either help me or you can go somewhere
else
boom cuz there's a lot of rooms and
there's people who've chosen not come
back to my room but I help more often
than not I see people change their
behavior and adjust their joke and they
get funnier and they're welcome you know
like it courtesy of windy PA all you got
to do is bomb and I'll tell you what
it's just I think it's important to give
people feedback I don't think we do that
enough as comics we're very guarded and
like yeah additive in that way it's true
even just like against getting feedbacks
we don't want to tell us what to do know
much is the best of all you do is we
just want it all to be magic really yeah
there's something to like trying can be
taboo oh yeah look really dorky try yeah
but our nerd promoting themselves yeah
getting jobs in that and that a lot of
that is just like our own negative
self-talk that tells us well because I
mean I've done the same thing with like
promoting like my classroom and my post
in the podcast too much something that
people are gonna judge even I've been
doing this like low over nine years and
I'm style still I've gotten better at
stifling that voice right but I mean it
literally took me up until last year to
just let go of why isn't this club
booking me every time I have it's gone
great do they not know who I am
it took me literally like eight years in
the game to be like oh that doesn't
matter it's out of my control
yeah it's wasted energy yeah no I think
that's a big thing to remember and I
something I've written about my blog a
lot cuz I've felt that a lot of just
like that why not mean kind of thing and
I think it's important to remember like
no matter what comedy scene you're in
like the biggest baddest show and your
comedy scene is only important in your
comedy scene you leave any other city
and maybe something a lot heard of it
maybe someone has talked about it before
but realistically no one gives an f that
you did the best room in Dayton Ohio
yeah you know no one even cares that you
did like the biggest free show in
Atlanta like it's who cares yeah it's
not important what do you got show me
your media kit like show me your product
you have scripts have you made anything
like no one's gonna care that you told
them you totally killed at a bar show
that all your friends think is really
cool yeah that that company isn't gonna
book you to their holiday event because
you
great at this like show that's really
popular there's kind of yeah they're
gonna look for the professionalism oh
they have a resume they have a media kit
oh they're they're writing a lot they
have a schedule like they're a professor
I can find out where they are and like
what they're doing other people are
booking them for things other people are
hiring them for things yes
yeah it's so much more important to
compete with yourself and like focus on
the internal stuff you can do because
otherwise we'll just spend your whole
time just chasing spots and being drunk
at shows yeah you know and it's it's
it's easier said than done and like that
it was a process for me to where I did
go through phase wreck I don't even care
anymore and then it would slowly creep
back you know like but now I care more
than ever and now I have actually like
released it finally but it did take just
taking the step in that direction of
like okay I need to focus on what only I
can control and just that and over time
that became my main focus but it was a
process of like okay I'm doing it oh
then there's that negative again but
it's not enough for no one cares that
you're doing it that's what I thing for
me lately I've been crying and pouting a
lot about how I feel like I'm doing a
lot for the scene by like building new
rooms and trying to give people
opportunities and then I get my feelings
hurt when they don't show up for them
and I'm just like and it makes me sad
because you know there's comics that I
you know kind of came up with you know
starting here that I like feel like we
became comedy buddies and they choose to
go to a different open mic instead of my
open mic or like they choose a good a
different show instead of my show even
though I like offer them a spot right
offer them buckets you know like trying
to give them opportunities and reason to
be there but like I'm just not the
choice and that hurts my feelings a lot
cuz like people I really like and I
think they're so funny and I want them
to want to work with me but I'm not as
important as other people are to them
and that's more you tell yourself yeah
and that's what it feels like you know
because barely blowing me off for these
other things and it hurts my feelings
all the time but I also need to like
look at like all the people who are
coming to my shows who are performing on
my open mic and who look at me as like a
goal and look at what I'm doing as like
cuz I think that's an important thing to
remember too is that like no matter what
stage you are in anything at some point
they're sewn below you and what you're
doing is their goal yeah like
you're someone's goal like you've got
what someone else wants desperately and
that's awesome like I appreciate where
you are and it's like I'm really [ __ ]
talking what you have and what you don't
you suppose to what you don't and that's
been like a really good like coping
mechanism for me because always I get
really caught up in it and I have this
feeling like everyone's hanging out
without me no none of my peers think I'm
funny like yeah I get booked and I'm a
good comic but no one really likes me
like I'm like no one here likes but it's
almost like when you're on stage and
like you're getting laughs but you're
like but they're not loud enough yeah
it's not good and now they're not crying
while they last scream yeah you know
I'll be in the middle of a set and be
like it's just not oh not one person has
[ __ ] their pants what's the point but
yeah that's like the more you do it like
the you know it's it's like drugs like
the more you do you're chasing a
different high and a certain point like
that doesn't fulfill you anymore and
you're like I want more how do I get
more and I think that's when you need to
start doing something different instead
of doing more of what you're doing you
need to try a new thing like when you
start feeling impatient like you're not
doing enough and that was a big thing
for me I started getting itchy with
stand-up like I wasn't doing enough so I
was like I'm gonna focus on sketches and
then I was like no I'm gonna focus on TV
writing and then I wrote a bunch of
pilots and I wrote a bunch of specs and
I started teaching other people how to
do that and it was like okay now that's
a new skill I have yeah and it's also
not enough no on to the next thing but I
think that's a good coping mechanism we
feel frustrated you know try something
else for a little bit shift your focus
there's so many arenas that connect and
today in comedy you got to do everything
mm-hmm you've got to be able to do all
of the things so it's important to take
classes it's important to watch other
shows it's important to go to other
kinds of theater and entertainment see
what they're doing
I've learned a lot about hosting from
watching wrestling not gonna lie like
great like indie wrestling has been a
big thing for me learning about that
like showmanship and attitude and
controlling crowds like there's so many
things that relate into how you come out
on stage that you can adapt you know who
is your favorite wrestler oh my god I
don't even know it's literally eyes like
well I have a bunch of friends who
follow indie wrestling in Chicago and I
always seem like clips I was a golfer
there doing today
oh man they got a pop punk band with
them what they got married at the show
the drama but yeah like I I really love
that documentary about gorgeous ladies
of wrestling I haven't I'm so good I've
watched it probably like 40 times cause
like watching listening as women talk
about how they develop their stage
characters and their wrestling personas
and I'm like that's some deep personal
digging that you did turned it into the
goofy [ __ ] I've ever seen but it's also
like purely them you know and I'm like
that is so cool because I think it's so
important to have like a strong identity
as a performer I think that's what's
gonna carry you through I feel like
that's what's carried me is I feel like
I've always known like Who I am I've
always had like my standards and I feel
like that like sense of self really
shines through and how I interact with
people and I feel like I'm pretty good
at helping other people figure out their
thing too because I'm open and I'm
encouraging and I think that's carried
me very far in this industry
self-awareness is crucial and it's
something I've I've doubted with and
like I literally like last week had a
new pivot in like my self-awareness and
my approach and I had been been doing
these classes for a while and I had been
focusing my energy I felt like I got to
a crossroads kind of like you're almost
it was interesting timing of this cuz
like you're you're at this crossroads of
like okay I have my day job but then I
have my comedy and have a vision for how
to make comedy work so what do I do and
then I was at a crossroads where I kind
of lost sight of why I started comedy to
begin with and it wasn't I love helping
people I love connecting with comedians
my favorite thing is just on the way
here a comedian called me like I've
gotten to this festival I heard about on
your podcast it's great and that's my
favorite but I've been too focused on
like okay well I'm teaching classes
independently now well I've gotta do I
gotta have three tiers and I gotta have
a workshop once a month and then I got
to get these Skype calls and like and
then I was focusing so much on that as
opposed to but I'm a comedian
I started comedy because I love comedy I
should focus on me and like the more I
the more I'll be able to help people but
me spinning my tires trying to force my
way into helping people is not doing
anybody a survey so just last week I had
to take a step back I made like a
five-year plan and then broke it down by
a year okay by year one I want to
achieve this by year two three all the
way up to four and five and I'm now
focusing on like getting booked and
making this podcast like an actual
Comedy Network and totally it took I
mean it took like you said you know
trial and error and you try different
things and eventually I came just full
circle - why did you start comedy yeah
what's what is this all for well yeah
cuz yeah I do I can relate to a little
bit too with like starting like
producing more and then I started
teaching last year and you know trying
to like generate that and maintain that
it definitely takes up a lot of the time
and I felt like I wasn't being as
creative as I wanted to be and even
though I was trying to like write with
my students when we were in class and
trying to also like workshop stuff with
them I also needed to focus on them and
not me because I'm the instructor and I
did feel like I wasn't like creating new
stuff enough and I had to kind of like
take a little hiatus from some of my
other like sketch things look so the
point I was like directing a sketch team
I was running Don't Tell I was running
the open mic I was teaching a TV spec
writing class I was teaching a stand-up
class and we were still no we weren't
doing good evening tonight anymore but
through all that it was like when do I
write new jokes when do I
yeah the 20 minutes before the open mic
on Tuesday that's when I write my new
jokes they're all garbage and then I'm
gonna bad mood the rest of the night you
know I take because I didn't spend the
time working so yeah it's important it's
easy to like kind of let the business
like run run you over a little bit cuz
you also you know you have to do so much
admin work when you're doing that you've
got to do like I don't know if you have
someone for your website but you know
you got like update stuff you've got to
do social media
you got answer emails like there's so
many hours of work you have to do even
before you get to the comedy part when
you're running like a comedy business as
an individual which is what you are a
business which isn't super hard for me
to like manage this year I feel like I'm
not generating as much new content as I
want to but I think yeah it's important
to kind of pick what am I gonna focus on
because you can't do everything at once
exactly so yeah right now I'm focusing
on building the business and you know
after that's going well I can hire other
people to help me run stuff and then I
can go to or more I can go do this like
it's about picking those pieces apart
like we're talking about before like
doing it step by step
but yeah it's easy to forget the
creative part because you're so busy
trying to mark yourself and when the
comedy is your job and you're like but
this is a business and like I even went
so far as to like well maybe I'll do
public speaking about comedy because I
was looking into the speaking world and
they're getting like 10 grand a gig and
I was like well maybe I'll do that for a
little while and just save up money and
then come back and it's it's I got a
friend who's like doing you know he's on
American Ninja Warrior
right he's like on the new season of
American Ninja Warrior cuz he's like a
very fit man he's also a comedian he's
also one guys who runs Don't Tell
company what Alex Weber but he also has
done like TED talks about like comedy
and like physical strength and like
overcoming challenges and he's like a
he's like a motivational speaker as well
as like performer and an athlete and I
look at him and I'm like I gotta figure
out what that guy it's for breakfast
right he's doing it but yet so it's like
you see like those gigs on those big
engagements you're like okay maybe I
need to focus on that but then I feel
like it takes me away from like what I
came here but it's like with me if I do
that make money then I can come back to
what I wanted but I get really worried
about waking up like ten years from now
and like just doing the same thing I'm
doing now and not feeling like I've
developed creatively
yeah I get nervous because yeah the
business part is really cool but the
whole point is the coffee
yeah that's why I wanted to share that
cuz like at every level a comedian is
like doubting themselves a truck we're
all like still just trying to figure it
out and I know people I mean I've got
friends who are writing staff of a major
shows I got a friend who just became the
head writer the James Corden show and
like he's still anxious about not
getting booked at certain venues or like
whether or not he'll get into stuff like
he's still worried about his job you
know people have all sorts of problems
you know I have friends who are on
staffs that have been there for a long
time people just started there's anxiety
across the board because it's all the
risk and it's all vulnerability and you
know at the end of the day what we're
really trying to do is convince people
to like us
like the hard thing to do so yeah I
think it's important no matter what
level you are people are struggling and
I feel like I'm trying really hard to be
transparent about that and like let
people know that like I don't have it
figured out and it's okay that you don't
do I'm like we can all help each other
no matter what level we're at you know
yeah I think it's important to be
transparent as well and like almost be
not trying to be the hero but yeah I
don't act like oh yeah it's just so easy
I just wake up like this with
opportunities yeah no no no you gotta
let people know how you did it
mm mm just cruel I don't know it just
seems I was just also well don't you
want to share like that struggle and
like it the pat on the back that comes
with it like people aren't gonna like
you as much if they think you just woke
up hot and funny like you gotta let
people know that you were an ugly
unfunny person for a long time so when
do you think you're gonna jump in oh
when is what was the deadline with the
when they take on day care how long is
yeah so like well they're about to turn
to we're gonna start potty training them
soon and that's really the breaker once
they're potty-trained we can ship them
off to anywhere we want we can ship them
up but yeah I mean I'm hoping that I can
stick around I can make the schedule
work but my goal is by 2020 to not be
doing at least not that good hours I'm
doing I'm hoping to at least you know if
I don't fully quit my job maybe we can
coordinate something more in part time
or maybe I you know whatever start
taking that late transition job that I'm
looking for I'm hoping that the job I
have now can be part of that but I also
like realistically I know it's like time
to do something else
you know yeah so I'm hoping by January
I'll be like okay January that's like
kind of my goal is to sort of see try
and get myself right in this next six
months okay um I've kind of like made
like a short-term plan and it's like if
I can accomplish that plan in this next
six months then I feel like I'll be like
on a good path to like take the leap
because I do know I can't do anything
else until I have more time like
realistically I need more time and I'm
not going to get that unless I changed
my work situation so one thing has to
happen first oh yeah yeah I want to give
myself some time to you know save some
money make sure my plan is as viable as
I think it is
yeah kind of test it out and hopefully
have it work out plan plan have a plan
plan self self-awareness and having a
plan it's true and being willing to
adapt the plan that's been a big thing
because sometimes your plan does not
work and you just have to like pivot or
you have to yeah and you just have to be
prepared that's been a hard thing for me
too because I I am kind of type a and I
plan plan plan and then stuff doesn't go
the way I want it and I like have a
total mental breakdown for a minute and
like no meltdown I'm a crier that's just
who I am I didn't notice the fire this
interview you're like multiple times
like I just bought I just cry all the
time
it's very helpful but honestly my skin's
never looked better since I started
crying
honestly I used to never cry and then I
got real in touch with myself I cry all
the time
Chloe glowing um but yeah I think you
just gotta take it one day that's
somebody I like I like you you having a
plan it's like you're not just
complaining about why not me you're like
well let me let me try something
create a plan so I would challenge all
comics if you're not where you want to
be I think great things we've learned is
to okay if you're not where you want to
be figure out where you want yeah that's
important don't just say I want more I
want better spots pick some spots that
you cific pick some shows they're
tangible especially in Atlanta there's
so many great shows that have Buckett
spots on them and you show up you get in
that bucket you perform that's your
audition for that Booker yeah and that's
how you're gonna get booked on other
shows and I'll say you know with my own
show I mean the system that I've
specifically set up is I've got the open
mic on Tuesdays to see people for their
first set or their new set whatever and
then from there if I see them I like
them then I'm gonna invite them to come
to my show at a matza on Mondays and
give them that showcase of that like 8
to 10 minute slot if they do well there
and I like them it seems like other
people do I might let them come do like
a shorter set on don't tell which has
like the big game audience you know so
like my whole plan is to vet people cuz
I don't want to have to be chasing
people around a book I want to know that
who's funny so I'm setting up shows for
people to come show me what they can do
and it's so interesting how many people
are not picking up on that opportunity
I'm putting out there and I'm being very
clear I tell everyone this is how I
booked my show
headus did the same thing exactly become
to my shows come to the open mikes and
then you might get booked yeah just I
will tell you I will always tell you how
I booked you or how if I will or will
not do if you send me a clip I've got on
windy peach I've got a submission form
all you got to do is put in your name
and your email on your clip it will come
to my inbox I will watch it if I think
it's funny I will offer you a spot on
something you know or if you're gonna
use want notes I've had people message
me asking for feedback on their sets
like new comments I might and I'll do
that for people too you know all you got
to do is send a tape and I feel like the
biggest thing is like you always have to
ask because people probably have
forgotten you exist cuz I didn't see you
in like the last 48 hours write
something you know there's a lot of
people especially hosts they see a lot
of comics so it's not that people don't
like you or ignoring you they just
forgot you exist you got to remind him
nothing that's showing up to the show
helping clean up afterwards saying a
message like hey this show was so fun I
would love to be considered what can i
what can I send you asking if you can
send a clip is great most people will
say yes and then they'll either wash it
or they won't and that's all you can do
but I feel like sitting around
complaining about not having enough
spots without ever having a specific
goal you're that's you're gonna stay an
open-mic purgatory for the rest of your
life you know purgatory is such a great
yeah it is it is so yeah you just got to
figure out what you want and then start
approaching people about how to get it
and sometimes it's as simple as asking
someone above you like hey do you know
how they booked so-and-so show or like
hey do you think so and so be open to
getting a tape and if you're talking to
me I'll tell you whether or not to do
that you know like I'll let you know
what I know I'm not gonna keep secrets
know what know what you want who has it
talk to them about it yeah don't ask if
you can have it
Oh ask how you can get it that's so
important don't come in assuming you
deserve it just ask what you can do to
be considered yes and if they're nice
they'll book you or at least tell you
how and if they're not nice and they
don't tell you how maybe it's not that
good of a show I don't know who wants to
do a show for someone who's not gonna
help you learn how to do their show ever
I just I don't know I don't like people
who play things that close to the vest
I don't yeah I don't need it there's
enough to go around that's what I don't
yeah there's so much
my favorite part about this podcast is
getting people to share like the recipe
mm-hmm because it's like why mean used
to have to cook it like it's gonna come
out differently yeah there's so many
different ways to make it you know you
have to do the work yeah you just got to
figure out what applies to your skills
and to your goals and do those things
and it's different for every person you
don't have to follow everyone's path
definitely make your own it's gonna be a
lot more enjoyable this well first all
right we're gonna wrap this up but first
thing we're gonna do is we're gonna come
back in January
yeah 820 because we're both we're both
like you said a six-month plan I I
actually have a six-month plan for this
year as well in addition to like the
year-long here all the way long term so
we're gonna come back in January we're
gonna revisit and it's funny this is
halfway through the year hmm so you just
jumped the line as well we're gonna
release this next week I have like six
in front of you and we're gonna jump the
line because I feel like halfway through
the year we probably all started out of
like this is the year and then halfway
through we're like oh no so now we're
gonna help everyone come back come to
get to Center create a six month plan
figure out what you want and then now
start connecting with the people that
have it yeah you like that yeah I'm so
excited a good idea yeah okay so we're
gonna come back in January of 2020 and
we're gonna follow up on this six-month
plan you comedians create your six month
plan
hold yourselves accountable there's a
Facebook group called the hot breath
Comedy Network if you want to join it
share maybe your six month plans on
there we can all come together and start
to help hold each other accountable
connect with Sam directly just like you
reach out to me and you're like this was
so helpful or thank you for posing this
lets Sam know as well start connecting
with her she is she's good people people
let me help okay
so reach out to her let them know where
everything where they can find you oh
yeah
so all social media handles I'm what Sam
just said or Wendy peach comedy is where
you could follow on my company Sam
Gordon comedy calm as my website Wendy
peach calm is the businesses website you
can find my Facebook page for both me as
a comedian and windy page and then
follow don't tell on all social media I
will say don't tell their Instagram they
often give away cash prizes and free
tickets and all sorts of fun stuff so
it's a great account to follow but yeah
come out to a show come say hi I'm very
approachable and honestly I've lived
here for 3 years and I've got a lot of
friends so it's hard to make friends
when you're so busy you mean like you
don't get a lot of social time so I'm
always looking for new people to hang
out with so people care you know people
care people care like look if I got hit
by a bus like people there'd be like a
Facebook page about it like if someone
would set up like a GoFundMe like you
know look about alone but yeah I know it
is it can be a lonely world doing comedy
we also often feel like we've got more
friends than we do because we all hang
out at shows but yeah come say hey come
be social yeah I wanted to you did this
Facebook post I'm I wanted to read it
mm-hmm at the beginning of this but um
and then I pulled it out halfway through
and I was like this will be the time
then I think it's not what I wanted to
read this for all comics just moving
forward as you embark on this that
you're not alone in this but this you
posted this on it was like in June June
11th dude does this look for me this was
the one we had talked about doing this
several times cuz we just share the same
like passionate energy and then you
posted this and I was just like this
needs to happen now because I've been
here several times and even like very
recently as like last week I was here in
terms of like what what am i who why am
I even here so this is I don't know did
you delete this after do you remember if
you're deleting I don't know okay it
opens I do delete posts cuz like too
much going on on them you know okay
comment and I'm like alright well I
shared my feelings I don't need to hear
yours you know
so this says or do you want to read it
oh you
here use this audiobook okay Sam Gordon
this is June 11th I'll definitely get
embarrassed and delete this later but
people keep telling me I'm killing it
lately and I just want to be honest that
my comedy Hustle is not as cool as it
looks don't get me wrong I'm really
proud of all the things I have done -
DIY my way into comedy but I feel really
burned out and I wish someone would see
what I do and just pick me for something
it would be very validating if the
universe could send me confirmation that
I'm doing okay because I feel like a
loser exclamation mark I have been
working very hard and creating a lot of
opportunities for other people while
waiting for my turn to come up I'm
trying to trust that it will but if the
next time you see me you could tell me
something you respect about me or think
I'm good at that might help get through
another year of waiting to catch a break
and I commented the universe called and
wants to hear you on hop it's like a
glimpse into the side of comedy that
people don't see a lot yeah we can get
lost in the Netflix specials and like oh
this is so awesome but like that that's
comedy then yeah you're not alone in
these feelings yeah every I've
interviewed people 2530 years into this
game we all go through these ups and
downs so it's like at any level you're
not alone you're not immune so we're
here yeah to help you not feel alone so
connect with us on all the social media
if you do want to learn more about hot
breath and all the episodes hot breath
podcast calm is the best place to check
out the blog we have going on pick up
merch there's also a fun donate button
in the top right it would mean the world
if you just slipped in a couple dollars
there no donation too small but that
keeps this hot breath averse free and
supporting awesome people like Sam here
so all that being said go forth six
month plan
what do you want kind of people that
have it how can you get it yeah I think
we can even be set up like a list in the
group of like where's some tangible
goals like hey if you're at this level
maybe you should try to aim for this or
like maybe you tell us what your goal is
we can give some advice on how to
accomplish that or get some conversation
going great ideas yeah it'll be
different for everybody at every level
but I think there's a way to connect
with whoever you're hoping to work with
if that's what you want boom alright how
breath averse you have your homework
we'll see you next Monday bye
[Music]